[Music]
in 1987 President Ronald Reagan famously
demanded Gorbachev the head of the
Soviet Union to tear down that wall his
speech laid the foundation for this
moment just two years later thousands of
East Germans canned outside the German
Embassy in Hungary demanding access
across the border and three fundamental
things freedom safety and reunification
now I wasn't born yet because of that
moment when I grew up in Berlin there
were no more walls
I never even questioned the right to
safety and freedom and so this happened
four years ago thousands of people were
stranded at the Hungarian border yet
again but this time it wasn't German
citizens who pleaded for the world to
pay attention
it was Syrian refugees this fact a
movement across my country images like
this of people welcoming refugees into
Germany went around the world I was so
proud so I decided to leave my corporate
job in the UK and moved back to Berlin
to support my government in absorbing
the 1 million refugees that ended up
arriving that moment changed my life
since then I've met some incredible
refugees and worked with some of the
most dedicated people I know who try to
support them their strengths and
resilience has become my source of
inspiration and Drive but at the same
time the public conversation has changed
the outpouring of support has turned
into protest and fear instead
tearing down walls we are building them
this scares me I don't fear that we have
lost control of our borders I fear that
we have lost control of our fundamental
values what has happened let's start
with the basics there's 68 million
refugees in the world today these are
people who have been forced to flee from
their homes because of conflict and
violence take Syria a country that has
become synonymous with the world's
refugee crisis the Syrian war started
nine years ago with the Arab Spring
after 13 your boy was tortured and
murdered for writing a pro Arab Spring
graffiti people went out on the streets
to protest peacefully but President
Bashar al-assad
responded with gunfire it's backed one
of the deadliest civil wars in our
modern times leaving 500,000 people
Deb's and 12 million forcefully
displaced that is two-thirds of the
entire country these are people who
stood up to demand freedom safety and
democracy they fight for the values we
preach and we ignore them and so they
literally showed up at our borders at
the height of the crisis sometimes
thousands of refugees came into just
Berlin in a given week on one of my
first days working for the government
there I went to visit an old
decommission airport at the heart of the
city the local state office had resorted
to seizing whatever they could find as
shelters because they simply wasn't any
space then included school gyms and the
old airports for you but what I found
was this if thousands bunk beds
and into what looked like an industrial
hall 2,000 people lived here people from
different cultures different families
from all over the world the echo made
the noise level almost unbearable there
was no peace and quiet no privacy some
of the people who came looking for
freedom and safety had to stay here for
almost two years they were safe
yes but free not really I remember a
social worker who came and pleaded with
us to help a refugee who was severely
disabled and suffered from PTSD placing
him here was cruel not just for him but
really for everyone
imagine trying to sleep whilst he was in
during his night terrors he needed
individual care but we simply weren't
able to provide it if there's one thing
I learned that day it is that no one
chooses this life you placed in it if
you're out of options and there's
something else I learned if you're
facing the humanitarian crisis it forces
you to make trade-offs Hugh gets
prioritized for individual care and who
doesn't he gets to stay and who doesn't
all of these decisions have a tremendous
human cost and not just to the refugees
but really to all of us accommodating
refugees requires a sacrifice and some
of it might be small like getting used
to sharing your public spaces with
people who look really different to you
or giving up your school gym for two
years and some is big like having
government resources diverted away from
your local projects it really is no
wonder that the cycle of his
three always follows the same pattern
when it comes to refugee movements in
1938 67 percent of Americans were
opposed to granting refuge to Jewish
people fleeing Nazi persecution my own
grandma came to Germany as a refugee
she was dremen but she grew up in the
Sudetenland a small strip between
Czechoslovakia and Germany after World
War two all the Germans living there had
a day to pack their bags and leave even
though she shares a nationality and a
language with the people in her new
hometown she was not greeted with
kindness
my point is this is a vicious cycle of
history every generation perpetuates and
this crisis really is no different if we
judge previous generations on whether or
not they took a stance will future
generations not do the same to us I
worry because I know that this sacrifice
is painful what's working in government
I organized a town-hall meeting in one
of the most liberal district of Berlin
where you can find welcomed refugee
posters on every street corner we had to
ask the residents to give up a tiny
piece of their large neighborhood park
for a new refugee shelter turns out the
people were furious I know that we can
take everyone in but that is not what we
are debating right now instead we're
turning a blind eye again we're coming
up with all the creative arguments for
why we don't have the resources to help
why are we not best place to help why in
fact isolation is the best answer
we are back at the vicious cycle of
history I know that we can break it but
for that I'm asking you to make a
sacrifice to stand up for the values I
know we all share and that might not be
today I'm asking you to remember this
talk when the time comes for you to make
a choice do I truly open my arms even if
it costs me or do I look away and that
cost might be small like speaking up
publicly even if it's risky or giving up
its hiney space in your neighborhood
Park or it might be big like going out
of your way to create opportunities for
Refugees in your future companies every
decision every action counts previous
generations might have not gotten it all
right with our countries share history
in literally tearing down walls together
I don't want to be the generation that
builds them back up thank you
[Applause]
[Music]